than a year-long search for consistency
for zach gallany is your ram truck
starting pitcher
for the diamondbacks tonight 18 starts
with a 4-3-4 era
yeah he's one of those guys got the good
fastball change up curveball sliders
little cutter whenever he has to use it
so
he's going to be working again tonight
and trying to get uh some rhythm back
there with murphy behind the plate
fastball's right there strike three says
ben may 93 from gallon and that's two
ounces of the first
this is chopped to third josh van meter
is there
and a good start for zach gallon a one
two three first diamondbacks coming up
and it is spencer howard getting his
11th start of the season and it'll be
his fourth with the texas rangers 0-3
record so far six and a half era
throwing just seven in the third innings
with the rangers 35 and two-thirds
overall he has allowed four home runs
this season
this one in the air to left down the
line into that corner and martin has
just enough room it's a one two three
first inning for howard he only needed
nine pitches to get it done go to the
second no score
still holding over there ahmed backhands
that and they get the force on solac at
second
no score diamondbacks and the rangers
it's still kind of the go-to for him
well he gets a swing and a miss by
peralta his first strikeout of the night
well not surprising to see a fastball he
throws a lot of them you get a 3-2 count
there's that four-seamer with a little
bit of extra carry
to get it
and this ball
pretty hard out there to right field but
right to dj peters and the inning is
done it's another one two three
for spencer howard now the third inning
becomes kind of a question we go to the
third no score
woodward says the rangers adore charlie
culberson just a professional great
teammate positive energy every day
and zach gallon gets strikeout number
two to start the third
it's this one up in the air for dalton
varsha in right field
and zach gallon
through three no score
all right jordan lyles
takes over now for spencer howard
fundraise and angels just underway at
pepco martial
as the game's first hit
there goes varshall on the 2-2
and he's in there
stolen based number five for dalton
varsio and a full count out on that
three and two
punches that one near the left field
line martin on the run he makes a great
running grab and foul ground varsio able
to tag up
and rojas gives the diamondbacks the
lead that's a good at-bat right there
after he fell behind o2
bouncer right side of the infield
so lack is there throws it over the
first in time and they retire van meter
the diamondbacks leave a couple but they
get that first run of the night we go to
the fourth inning it's one nothing
well i don't know about that is this one
lined over second unless you told me
that that's a
basically where yoni hernandez and now
is your lives come too no
no
there are multiple freshmen basketball
teams okay right there there's an angle
there's a camera angle where it looks
really yellowy and when i was there i
thought it looked really yellowy
nathaniel lowe strikes out but
a stolen base for hernandez he didn't
even draw a throw
gallon with a look at second
set comes to the plate and that ball hit
out to the alley and right field it gets
down hernandez got a good jump off
second he'll score easily
a dj peters rbi single ties the game at
one in the fourth inning
up the middle and that's a base hit
peter's turn second base we've got to
get back he does
geez
he's got a big stride i was thinking the
same thing as a pretty unnecessary
aggressive turn there from dj peters now
of course you do that in case there's a
bobble but even then
i don't think he would have went it's a
two away for jason martin
martin
reached down a fielder's choice in the
second inning he's over one
this one on the ground and into right
field that's a base hit peters is in
solac following
the throw cut off
and martin with a two run single
gives the rangers the three to one lead
rangers hurt him for three runs and
that's a fair ball and that bangs its
way out into right field martin around
third base but they'll stop him on the
double by culverson
[Applause]
five hits in the inning
[Music]
haven smith belts one to right center
and that gets to the wall
it's rolling around on the warning track
out there smith headed for third payment
is in there with a triple
fourth triple this year for pavon smith
he's a third down with two outs
this one up the middle the diving catch
by yanni hernandez
hello
how about that little play from the
mosquito
ending over
and in front of his family absolutely
amazing johnny hernandez they're excited
about it the signs are out
rojas is all for one he drove in the
diamondbacks only run with a sac fly and
he swings right through strike three how
about jordan lyles
in the fifth inning
oh shorts
he answers back after the rangers go
quick in the top of the fifth here's
jordan lyles finishing off rojas with a
pretty good look at this
looking at the rangers they've been sat
down straight
nobody wants to talk about that
but this will be seven in a row right
here
pop up
to culberson and it's a quick sixth
inning another seven pitch
half inning for lyles three to one
[Applause]
this one on the ground and through
that's a base hit for leote tavares his
first of the night
and he is almost caught in a rundown
one two pitch
and that's on the ground third base
diving stop culberson hops up nice row
and they get carson kelly for the first
out of the seventh inning it's been some
really good infield defense tonight from
the rangers and charlie culverson all
year long has done a good job but
charlie gets to this ball and it's a
nice strong throw over to first base
two-two pitch and a swing and a miss a
strikeout of our show
two away here in the seventh inning
basically just knocked out what the
first month of the season right because
of covid
there's a better way to do it it seems
like maybe we're on that path
ramos strikes out swinging an eighth
pitch at bat however the number of
ridiculous things that happen in this
game and you know we don't send a move
tend to move on those quite as quickly
high-bounding bunt right back to the
mound
and a nice plate by jordan lyles to get
martay diamondbacks with just three hits
tonight on one pitch and this ball
in the air left field and fittingly
jason martin will catch the final out of
the ball game lyles
with seven innings in relief to get the
win his eighth
of the year and the rangers have won
three straight
on the road
you